[Music]
it's always good news when we get a
sponsor but I was especially happy to
know that a business owned and operated
by our own Andy Richter was advertising
on our show this is exciting I didn't
know you how to business oh no thanks
Conan I'm very excited and all I ask you
in the home audience is before this ad
runs go wake up your Grandma and Grandpa
and tell them to watch ok oh yeah nice
oh yeah give it to me oh yeah that's
good I love it
hi I'm Andy Richter what I'm not in
front of the camera with that guy I'm
behind the camera
taking pictures of old people come on
give it to me show me that huh that's
because I'm the president and owner of a
key all-stars
the very first modeling school photo
studio and talent agency for seniors who
want to be in pain medication ass cuz
let's face it people over 65 our youth
obsessed society is done with you they
pretty much just want to gather you all
up into giant Nets and dump you out at
sea
so anyway oldsters why not show society
you still have something left in the
tank and get paid good money for making
Ally faces here at a key all-stars
you'll learn all the classic poses like
all these aching hands like goddamn war
back my arthritis is acting up that tuna
didn't agree with me it hurts just to
sit down and why won't the good Lord
just take me now even after your
instructions I'm still not a good actor
no problem so come on down to inky All
Stars
because you're not dead
you're gonna make a lot of money
I sure do
you